[Musique]
bonjour à tous je serais très heureux de
vous retrouver les 4 et 5 septembre
prochain à port marly pour la rentrée
des jeunes républicains
c'est important que l'on soit tous
ensemble unis et rassemblés autour des
jeunes et qu'on donne un souffle nouveau
de l'oxygène et de l'envié à cette
nouvelle génération politique de droite
alors j'aurai le plaisir avec vous
d'animer cette table ronde sur
l'écologie et l'économie comment on
concilie à la fois une exigence
climatiques écologiques avec bien sûr la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
c'est une question centrale la droite ne
doit pas abandonner l'écologie à celles
et ceux qui veulent en faire une
idéologie alors rassemblons nous venons
nombreux les 4 et 5 septembre prochains
soyons tout est tous mobilisés pour
défendre tout simplement la droite de
demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]